all right well let's talk about the next
lie oh boy we got the story from the new
york post
boston social justice activist and
husband scammed at least 185 000 from
donors so sayeth the feds they're being
hit with i think it's 18 different uh
uh charges federal charges they say a
high-profile social justice activist in
boston and her husband used a non-profit
they founded uh to scam at least 185 000
from donors who included a black lives
matter chapter and the local da's office
federal authorities alleged monica
cannon grant and clark grant allegedly
treated their violence in boston
organization as a personal piggy bank to
pay for rent shopping sprees delivery
meals visits to a nail salon summer
vacation trip to maryland i heard that
they were going to bubble gum shrimp
that was one of the things that was that
was heavily reported
they're going to mention the following
year she was named best social justice
advocate by boston magazine and one of
the boston globes bostonians of the year
when will people stop falling for this
stuff should we went through the list
again should we run through the list the
trayvon martin story what was initial
report that a white guy
saw a black kid and then attacked him
and killed him shot him what really
happened trayvon martin and george woman
got into a fight maybe one was maybe
zimmerman was in the wrong for
confronting him he was a neighborhood
watch and trayvon martin was walking
behind houses trayvon martin had him in
a ground pound position where he was on
top of him and pummeling him and then
george and shot him in the chest and
killed him zimmerman's hispanic we also
have michael brown hands up don't shoot
that was a lie that was total total loss
so remember the trayvon case nbc
actually deceptively edited the phone
call in order to make it sound like
zimmerman was describing trayvon martin
as being up to no good because he was
quote-unquote black they asked him what
does he look like he says he looks like
he's up to no good uh he's wearing a
black hoodie something along those lines
and they cut it together to say he looks
like he's up to no good black well the
other thing is the whole thing was a
sham with trayvon martin the the picture
that you saw everywhere was him when he
was like 11 or 12. right and he was much
much older and much much bigger they
made it out like george zimmerman like a
beat up like a 12 year old little punk
kid and he was much older than that
jesse's millet mm-hmm
at arbory story he was just jogging that
was a lie
it's just every single day there's a new
lie and these people they're written
house yeah the whole thing the the
entire thing was that oh he crossed
state lines and he shouldn't have that
gun as soon as i saw the story it was
very obvious to me and i think everyone
who saw that this was a case of
self-defense but then they started
mutting the waters by saying he had
broken gun laws or crossed state lines
and maybe he was looking for trouble but
not only could none of that be
substantiated i'm pretty sure they just
made all of it up because it was so
obvious that this kid was defending
himself and then what ends up happening
is people go well because they've
muddied the waters now we have to wait
for more answers before we can really be
sure and take a side and the story loses
momentum at a certain point i just you
know i i every every few months i say
something where i'm just like
it's all the same thing every day
we wake up we have a new story because
i've been i've been you know talking
about these stories and criticizing the
hoaxes
going on seven or so years now
um a little bit longer but doing the
actual youtube stuff and the podcast
stuff and at a certain point i'm kind of
just like
what's the point of saying it if it
doesn't change anything no no i think
that's the wrong mentality i wouldn't
lose hope there are a lot of people that
you're seeing the complete
decentralization of how people get their
information you had i was going through
like a lot of your episodes before
coming on and it's absolutely beautiful
450 000 people i mean for the last few
episodes watch your show yeah that is
beautiful and plus clips and and live
viewership isn't counted in that number
exactly and the thing is
what you're doing is exactly right you
are giving so many people the
information that they need and you don't
need to get a hundred percent of the
people you don't even need fifty percent
you need a solid ten to twenty five
percent of americans that are getting
solid information because those are the
people that are gonna go talk to their
family and friends and make sure that
they know the information there's like
10 to 25 percent of americans are just
helpless they're zombies then like
there's this 50 in the middle that are
actually persuadable and then there's
like us right like that are on the front
lines activist types i i think you're
actually doing the lord's work here and
i wouldn't lose hope i think there's a
lot to maybe maybe maybe that's it maybe
you know what needs to happen is we're
growing we're building infrastructure
we're expanding we're doing new shows
we're getting uh a new headquarters and
then i guess what really happens is in
10 or 15 years these cable networks
won't exist anymore exactly you all know
it's crazy
and this is no dick i'm a big fan of
it's always sunny but uh i heard that
it's always sunny in philadelphia had a
new season out
how many you guys are you guys have
heard of it's always yeah if you're
right it's now the longest running
live-action comedy series i guess so um
how many people how many viewers do you
think this show got
yeah on their seventh seventh season on
average how many people watched one
episode would you like to yeah no no no
not the premiere just like throughout
the season on average how many people
you think watched an episode if it's
always sunny in philadelphia i'm going
to pretend i'm not googling it
just tell me what you think 500 thousand
duckduckgo so it was it was about um i
think the premiere episode of season
seven was like 2 million wow and then
they would get like 1.3 to 1.5 million
per episode how many people do you think
watch
now
50 000. 300.
200 to 300 000 per episode i'm not
digging on i'm a fan i think it's always
sunny it's funny i don't really watch it
for the most part i think what happens
is
you know we've we've launched a couple
other shows we have the vlog we have
chicken city we have pop culture crisis
and i'm wondering if there's just
cultural swings in terms of what people
are interested in and sitcoms have just
you know there's too many options so
people are watching a bunch of different
shows
and
also
you know back when this show was at its
peak
we didn't have
this plethora of content and we didn't
have this plethora of streaming services
so what's happening is it's not so much
that people don't like the show it's
that over time people start using
technology and they start absorbing
information in different ways so the
reason i bring this up is that i think
it's entirely possible and likely that
within 10 or 15 years cnn just has
nothing and they're gone and then it
doesn't matter that people believe them
because there's nothing to believe
anymore they don't exist
however
10 years after that this show will be
outdated with limited viewership and
people will be in the metaverse or who
knows where it's all gonna be shim cast
baby i'll shrimp castle
you plug your brain right into the
neural link and then shim speaks
directly into your mind
i think what's going to end up happening
too unfortunately and people are going
to have to be vigilant about this is
as you have mentioned it's very easy to
covertly fund people online so i think
there are going to be a lot of people
who want to promote the establishment
narrative who are going to be very well
funded by people from within the
establishment who traditionally would
have just given their money to cnn or
placed advertisements on their network
you see it
you know you see it on youtube the the
favorite channels they're trying to prop
up cnn you know so much to perpetuate
all these lies uh are you guys familiar
with defiant l's yes yes yeah i think it
was defined else who had this it was um
so what they do is they show a tweet
from someone and then they show a
follow-up which is like
failure and it was like brian stelter
talking about you know we can't just
trust the cops on this justice mallet
thing you know we got to hear it out and
the next one is like justice millett
sentenced to 100 days in jail for our
crime folks
and it's just like yeah you know you
shouldn't be listening to people who are
i'll tell you this i can give him credit
for being a bit skeptical for sure
but it's like at some point you kind of
just say like
we know
or we should err on the side of that was
bs yeah well the skepticism only ever
runs in one direction every single time
we hear an accusation of racial hatred
we're told if we don't buy into it hook
line and synchro it's because we
actually just hate black people and not
that we want more evidence before we
jump to a conclusion
yeah but when it runs in the other
direction when it's when it's a blm
activist or
jesse smallett hoaxing or doing
something illegal or corrupt well then
we need to stop and wait for the
evidence and make sure that we have all
the facts straight before we i i can
think of when of one time there was a
mass campaign with uh racist vandalism
uh it was carried out by a bunch of
young white men it was when those white
supremacists put up those flyers
everywhere saying it's okay to be white
that's right yeah yeah which it is not
it is not it's yeah apparently it is not
disavow disavow apparently that's the
message they're sending
it was brilliant trolling you know
so you know those aren't familiar i
think most people know this they were it
was a white sheet of paper and it just
said it's okay to be white and people
would put the sticker on a pole and
they'd be like you're a white
supremacist and they're like that's
crazy this is an interesting discussion
i had with some of my friends and i just
want to ask you guys do you identify as
white me i don't i i but i thought
everybody knows i'm like yeah i'm more
catholic than anything yeah but actually
everybody knows the meme that i have
second generation mixed race family so
we don't have that that's like
i i guess there are people that are but
the idea is it's interesting the left
says see the reason you don't is because
you live in a world full of white people
so you're default yeah why would you
identify with what everyone else is but
in this is the problem with that
analysis firstly it's entirely
uncritical it's not actually looking at
specific ethnic backgrounds so irish
people and other ethnicities which were
generally more catholic as a matter of
fact such as the irish the italians the
polish were not considered white even
though we had white skin so i see
whiteness quote unquote is an identity
which has often been used to exclude
catholics well that's not something i
identify with that's partially what the
left critical race theorists argue that
whiteness is a political term and always
has been because there were white people
who who weren't white and they actually
argue now eastern europeans aren't white
like yeah well luke ankowski blonde hair
blue eyes they say is a person it's not
white well here's the issue in the
united states we have a very unique
racial history as a result of slavery
black people unfortunately lost a lot of
their ethnic identity because they were
brought over here forcibly and were not
able to retain the information on what
part of africa they came from
specifically and i think that's become
rejected unto people who we call white
now even though they would have
considered themselves irish polish
italian dutch when they came over here
they're thrown into an analogous
category of white even though they're
more or less identifying or had
identified until much more recently with
their ethnic identity rather than their
racial identity yeah this is exactly
what but this is this is one of the
arguments from the left that the reason
why you know there's no issue with black
pride or power is because they don't
have an ethnic identity they have a
racial identity because of what you just
described whereas for a white person you
could say you're proud of being irish or
scottish or ukrainian but not white yeah
but there's this kind of mountain valley
fallacy which they they engage in where
they will they will try to say things
like we're only against white privilege
in a system that places you on a
pedestal simply because of your skin
color we're not actually talking about
your skin color specifically but then
how do they identify you well buy your
skin color and they'll go after you and
say you're bad because you're white so
even though i don't identify as well you
want to talk about white privilege
justice millet yeah yeah
if whiteness is political then a
millionaire celebrity
who is propped up by the media and
defended when he commits a hoax and then
still has activists getting his back now
that's that's some kind of privilege and
at what point if whiteness is political
at what point would black people become
politically white it's like no it's a
serious that's a good question well i
mean they will call black conservative
activists white supremacists right bl i
mean literally white just means bad and
black means good that's how they use
these terms
yeah no and then
you have the other thing where like
they're redefining all these terms like
the adl came out and said define racism
right as um
the support of systemic racism like they
use the same words to define it which is
always a really bad sign yes but
basically the only way you can be
anti-racist or against racism is to
support marxism yeah like 100 percent
the adl
changed the definition of racism
to be about something like racial
dominance or something like that and
then had to change it again
like a week later and apologize because
something happened in like a jewish
community and they were like oh maybe we
should have thought about what we were
what we were claiming
because people started saying you
couldn't be racist against jewish people
or something like that and then in the
adl was like we better
revert our data should talk to whoopi
goldberg
oh yeah yeah yeah she she she she's she
knows all um apparently they used to
arrest people like tucker carlson and
tulsi gabbard for
you know pushing propaganda which is not
true
you know that whole whoopi goldberg
scandal got just memory holes like it's
like it never even happened oh right
that that would that's what it was
you're a writer right that's what
happened for anyone she came out that
was amazing she said that wasn't racist
that was just white people you know with
white people and then the adl realized
like
this this
this whiteness definition of racism is
really backfiring on you know like the
jewish community
maybe they shouldn't have tried playing
the vote game and then they realized
they had to change it back by the way i
i can't i saw a hysterical tweet someone
called them the adl the anti-definition
league oh yeah that was fantastic
thought that was fantastic very clever
yeah very clever but i'll also say too
it's always funny when people will
define racism as systemic racism
specifically because a i mean you lose
the ability to analyze racism at the
level of individual behavior rather than
just looking at it systemically but on
top of that you mentioned using
definitions
when or using the actual word you're
defining within the definition this is
the first thing you are taught in any
etymology class
if you want to define a word you cannot
use that word definition exactly so i
don't know if uh
i don't know if i mentioned this on the
show about the uh the black card revoked
we talked about that right maybe the
black card revoked
we went to uh uh i think we were in
altoona pennsylvania was it altoona
maybe not yeah i think it was i don't
know anyway we're at an airbnb
and they had a bunch of board games one
of the they had a pack of cards and it
was called black card revoked huh yeah
we talked about this with gothics oh
yeah yeah and uh oh that's right that's
right it was a card game that was
supposed to be
you know if you if it was it was for
black people to play and it was about
black culture and it asked questions
like what movie does every black person
have in their collection and i thought
it was racist and i'm like man i but hey
far be it for me it was made and
marketed by you know black people for
black people so there you go i guess i
don't know if it's racist or not if
these things are held by you know to be
true by them but one of the questions
was
if quote unquote they give reparations
what should they give and i was like why
is they in quotes
they in quotes is a reference to jewish
people right because when you're
referring to authorities
of of any power you just say they or
them
when it's put in quotes it's a specific
reference to jewish people and so i saw
that and i was like that's kind of weird
and and look
i don't i think maybe the people who
made this game are anti-semites it's
possible because they have ties to you
know high-profile politicians you know
we're we're looking at that story maybe
there's something there i don't know but
we know that there's a lot of prominent
black lives matter activists that are
deeply anti-semitic yeah we saw this
with the women's march these individuals
were forced to resign because they were
pushing insane conspiracy theories about
the jewish people yeah well look if you
tell people that any time a group of
people is successful it's because
they're stealing something from you
they're going to look at every
successful group of people and say
they're stealing something from us i
don't know why anyone thought that that
would start and end with white people
yeah
yeah that's why i can't stand the uh
just like the the general anti-semitic
like
so
anti-semitism in general is annoying to
me because it's the same it's the same
crt argument a privileged group of
people
dominate i'm like get out of here dude
like any look i know i there are ceos of
big companies and in media who are not
of a particular ethnic background it's
it can be anybody who works hard and
succeeds it's weird that people are like
i notice there's a whole lot of one
group of people in this industry that
proves it and i'm like dude that's a
privilege argument that's that's that's
a that's that's ridiculous argument i'm
not playing that game well and if you
know like i have friends who are
orthodox shoes and
the reason that they're
that they have influence and they that
they are successful is because they have
such a strong community like they
they're
it's family it's their it's their
friends like
they are so tight-knit like they help
pay for each other's kids like tuition
at school
they
i wish that like catholics had a
community similar to that yeah because
it's so strong and it's it's it's admire
admirable um really and we're getting
there honestly though i'm seeing it a
lot of places with with catholics yeah
the annoying thing to me about the
anti-semitism be it from blm or from
like white supremacist groups or
whatever it's like right now in new york
we've had this ongoing problem where
hasidic jews are being chased down and
brutally beaten and i'm just like where
is the great power structure to
intervene and tell the police to
actually deal with this hate that's
happening on the streets
and and but they don't why because the
people who run new york also are deeply
anti-semitic right so i mean it's like
for you know for the it's not bill de
blasio anymore but that dude is a far
leftist who probably held all of these
same insane beliefs and so this idea
that one group has privilege over the
others yeah sometimes some groups do but
i think the real issue is merit
merit drive and a little bit of luck
sprinkled on top chance favors they're
prepared but for the most part if you if
you are smart and you work really hard
you'll become successful but ultimately
we've talked about this before when it
comes to you know uh you know why you
see a high propensity of successful
jewish individuals could it be family we
know that family is a key indicator of
success regardless of your religious
background
as you are saying with the catholics and
well no but family is is everything
right like
lydia and i were talking about this
before the show family is why you get a
job family is why you go to work family
is why you love your country and why you
go to war and you're willing to die in
it so that your kids and your grandkids
can have a good life like family drives
everything and like it's like the social
science on this is so boring because
it's so predictable right like kids
raised in a loving household with
parents that take them to church on
sunday
are always the best performing group
they're they commit less crime they
don't commit suicide they don't get
addicted to drugs it's all very boring
and it's all basic and
and you know
the jewish community has like really
figured that out are you familiar with
the uh blue zones
no it's where
the uh there's like seven areas of the
planet where people haven't have a life
expectancy that exceeds a hundred or
whether it's like the highest propensity
towards having people live over 100
and so some researchers went to these
areas to figure out what do they have in
common
that may contribute to people living to
be over 100
and there's there's some interesting
things like they eat only till they're
about 85 percent full they don't overeat
but one of the one of the most
interesting things is they all they all
have a job
so they talked to this one he's a
japanese guy and he's like 102 and he's
chopping wood and they're like why are
you doing this shouldn't you be relaxing
and be retired and he's like well if i
don't do it who will
someone's got to get the wood and it was
for his community as her family
community and family was another big
part of it they're very close-knit and
tight-knit family families and
communities and the reason he had to
chop the wood was because he needed to
make sure everybody had this available
and if he didn't no one else would yep i
was also reading that
the highest um like the biggest spike in
when deaths occur is right after
retirement yeah so i think i think
people need to understand how how
important purpose is
in in a human's life without purpose
people become dejected depressed and
violent like we see with so many young
people these days and with purpose we
see a lot of people living to be over
100 years old yep that's right and
actually there's a lot of uh studies
that have come out over the last few
decades that show the benefits of not
just like having children uh like for
your mental health like down the road
but um like super old people when
they're around their grandkids a lot
their cognitive ability like they don't
they they can like reverse parts of
dementia and and erosion in the brain
it's it's really cool stuff and it's
it's i think you're right it's about
duty it's about responsibility it's
about purpose because when you lose that
like so many people when they retire
what my great-grandmother lived to be 95
and she didn't really start to
uh fall apart until she got out of her
daily routine she used to go to the the
library
she went to two uh goodwill stores the
thrift store and and uh and and the
goodwill she went to all the grocery
stores coupons as soon as she stopped
doing that she just kind of fell apart
think about it from an evolutionary
perspective you've got a finite amount
of energy in a certain area and
resources for a life form be it human or
otherwise
and so
what happens if
there is a a group of people or a group
of animals and several of them stop
producing for the rest of their herd
it's a strain on the herd and so then
what happens is the old you know it it
stands to reason that
life evolves
duty and purpose
because those who have a sense of duty
and purpose to each other are more
likely to survive more likely to have
kids and thus those traits are carried
on into the future with us thus family
and community are extremely important
the other interesting thing too is i
think purpose
you have to have a reason
to to do things to be alive otherwise
we're we're we're facing uh the rat
utopia experiment in my opinion are you
familiar we've mentioned it several
times and recently this is where they
put a bunch of rats in a you know
unlimited food unlimited water but
finite space
what happens when you don't have when
you don't have to fight for food what
happens when you don't have to do any
work you're lazy it's it's not just that
they found what
they found what they called behavioral
sync behavior started to break down
cannibalism emerged some rats would just
groom themselves incessantly and never
do anything they would engage in strange
behaviors and if they took one of the
rats out of the utopia and put in a with
a regular population its ideas would
persist and spread
so without purpose and without struggle
humans become
[Music]
likely in my opinion will become broken
you know and unhealthy yeah things fall
apart and i would say i mean even beyond
the sort of more materialistic darwinian
analysis we can just say that human
beings have deep spiritual needs there's
something about us that's very
mysterious and difficult to understand
and we're not contributing to something
that we understand is greater than
ourselves we do start to fall apart
yeah absolutely you you need that drive
uh
we we've looked into this actually a lot
on the economic side of things and the
funny thing is is like you would think
that you know having kids and getting
married would like you know put you
further back in terms of how much money
you're making it's actually not true and
there's this weird thing um a lot of
experts think that
when you have children it's actually a
bigger motivator to get a better job
start you know invest more in your
business so you can provide better but
it's it's
overall like when you when you have to
struggle you have to cut the fat right
you have to become more efficient um and
it just keeps you on your toes like and
family i think helps drive that
community helps drive that for a lot of
people they have no purpose and i think
yeah if you look at the millennial
generation i wonder what it could be
well there's two things no religion no
kids
yeah so then what do they live for
for people who a long time ago i'm not
saying this to say that um people uh
should be religious but certainly
without religion we can see people
become listless we used to have you know
people had faith they had community
religion served several purposes you
would go to church and that meant you
were with your community you were
communicating with each other you were
sort of synchronizing a lot of ways it
was a chance for the people who lived
next to each other to talk about what
was affecting them
so that was important yeah we don't have
that anymore people don't even talk to
their neighbors anymore it's really
weird it is when i was growing up like
i was always with my neighbors like we
they weren't then they all went to
different churches right i mean some of
my friends went to the same church as me
but like we had a neighborhood gang we
we would literally ride our bikes around
we'd build forts like and you would we
knew all the other neighbors even if
they didn't have kids and they would
talk to us and you know hang out yeah
block parties bargains and that doesn't
happen anymore especially in new york
man you go to new york and you live on
top of somebody you never met him that's
the weirdest thing to me yeah every
apartment i've ever had you know i'm in
new york city i was living off of um
myrtle in nostrand and there's uh there
are people my age behind me below me and
above me and it's like why don't i know
who they are no i could probably play
xbox together and order pizza if i just
talk to them talk to the guy never did
yeah just never happens yeah in a very
strange way the internet has actually
alienated us from our own actual
location there's been something
wonderful about the fact that it's given
access or given us access to people who
are nowhere near us but you stop forming
social connections with the people who
are right next to you
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there